will an aws certification get me an
idioms job now this is the question i've
been asked over and over again ever
since i started making youtube videos on
how to pass different adverse
certifications if you google how to get
a job in cloud computing it doesn't take
long for you to realize that every
second person is recommending getting a
certification but is an aws
certification alone enough to get your
job the short answer is no unfortunately
an aws certification by itself will not
guarantee your job at aws but there's
some things you can do on top of that to
help you maximize your chances of
landing that job if you're new to this
channel welcome i'm an associate
solutions architect working at amazon
web services and today i'll be
explaining why getting an aws
certification by itself won't get you a
database job but also what you can do on
top of that to help you get there before
we get started please make sure you give
this video a like and subscribe to this
channel if you'd like to see more videos
like this videos on how to land a job in
aws videos on how to pass different
adverse certifications and also what my
day-to-day looks like as a solutions
architect now aws certifications are a
pretty big investment to set an exam you
have to pay anywhere between 100 to 300
usd not to mention all the long hours
needed to prepare for the exam that's
why it definitely doesn't come as a
surprise that the most frequently asked
question is if i obtain an aws
certification and put it on my resume
will it get me the job that i want
let's have a look at a typical associate
solutions architect job at aws and work
backwards from the job description
if we take a look at the basic and
preferred qualifications you can see
that both soft skills and technical
skills are required this means that
during the interviews you won't just be
assessed on your technical skills they
will also be asking questions to figure
out how well you work in a team
environment and more specifically if you
apply to a job at aws they will also ask
you questions based off of amazon's 16
leadership principles and this is the
case with most jobs in the tech industry
the interviews will never be 100 focused
on assessing your technical capabilities
unfortunately a nativist certification
doesn't really help you build up your
soft skills so this is something you
have to get elsewhere but zooming into
the technical skills you can see that
one of the basic qualifications is to
have knowledge in one or more of the
following so you can see there's cloud
architecture solutions architecture
systems design software development and
as a preferred qualification they
mentioned that they'll like to see you
have experience implementing a
cloud-based technology solution in a
college project or while working for a
company and this is something where an
aws certification won't directly help
you on but through studying for an adb
certification the next step for you
could be to implement a cloud project so
as you can see from the basic and
preferred qualification an aws
certification does seem like a step in
the right direction in helping you get
started it really does provide a good
starting point but at the end of the day
an 80 certification is a multiple choice
exam the good thing though about
studying for adb certifications is you
probably have to follow video courses
and hands-on lab exercises to get that
practical experience in order for you to
pass that multiple choice exam and as a
result the practice that you get from
doing those hands-on exercises can
really help push you forward in starting
your own cloud project and the cloud
project that you start is something that
you can showcase to employers to really
help you stand out so what i'm trying to
say is an awf certification is a really
really good starting point for you to
build up your foundations and understand
aws services but having an aws
certification by itself doesn't really
show employers that you'll be able to
work in the real world environment and
actually help customers come up with a
cloud solution
so here comes the question what can i do
on top of getting an aws certification
to increase my chances of getting an aws
job i'll be covering this topic in more
detail in a later video so make sure you
subscribe to this channel to stay
updated but to give you an overview here
are some ways to help you stand out and
maximize your chances of getting a job
in the cloud industry so the first one
as i mentioned is cloud projects when
you study for certifications you might
have followed along with hands-on
tutorials that get you to become more
familiar with the aws console and adibus
core services but i'd recommend taking
this a step further to create your own
cloud project with the help of aws
documentation and existing projects on
github if you want the project to be
more relevant and useful for others you
could help your friends host their
websites on aws or even offer your
services on freelance websites like
fiverr this will help you become more
confident with your technical skills
whilst also showing companies you have
hands-on experience with aws another way
to stand out is by attending community
meetups and networking events where you
can meet others around you who are also
interested in aws and the cloud industry
this will help you stay motivated and
you can also share job opportunities and
resources with each other you can go
onto meetup.com to search for these
events or you can join our cloudbytes
community which is a group i started to
bring together tech with lucy's
subscribers if you're looking to prepare
for an aws certification looking to
start your career in the cloud or just
want to connect with others also
interested in aws and cloud computing
i'd recommend joining the cloudbytes
community on slack i'll put a link to it
in the description box below my third
and final tip is to prepare for
interviews as soon as you can many
people i speak to want to focus on
getting aws certifications first and
then practicing their interview skills
but getting better at interviews is
definitely something that takes time so
please make sure you do that alongside
your certification study also keep in
mind the point i mentioned earlier that
interviews will be a mix of technical
and non-technical questions so please
don't forget to prepare for both all
right so this brings us to the end of
this video thank you so much for
watching and if you have any questions
please drop them in the comments below
don't forget to join our cloudbath
community on slack and i'll talk to you
soon bye for now
[Music]